J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: Last time
about triphenylmethyl,
so I thought
you might like to see a
space-filling model of
triphenylmethyl, and feel it,
how it works.
Remember, it was very difficult
to find a way of
making tetraphenylmethane, which
means you have to take
this phenyl with its little hook
there
and get it into there.
So I'll pass this around and you
can try twisting it and
see if you can make
tetraphenylmethane better than
the people before Gomberg did.
And then there's a question of
whether you can make
hexaphenylethane.
So here are two
triphenylmethyls, one has the
hook in it, and one doesn't.
So the question is, can you put
those two together?
So Debbie, you're the first. So
whoever gets it should
bring it up and show it to us.
Now, the projector is warming up
here.
So we're speaking about
triphenylmethyl and then I
have a little second thought
about Friedel-Crafts reactions
that I'll give to you.
And then we're going to go on to
the next subject, which is
carbonyl compounds, once the
center projector
gets warmed up here.
So we talked last time about how
steric hindrance--
how you doing with your steric
hindrance there, Debbie?
STUDENT: Pretty poorly.
PROFESSOR: Pretty poorly, OK.
It's really tough to get these
things together when you have
these three propellers that all
have to twist because of
the way they run into one
another.
I still don't have my projector,
I don't know how it
got turned off.
I guess I did it somehow.
So it makes-- as Debbie's
finding out--
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: It makes
tetraphenylethane--
did you try hexaphenylethane?
STUDENT: That's even worse.
PROFESSOR: It's even worse?
OK.
So let us see.
It looks like it's on up there.
How are you guys doing?
Helen, Antonia?
Can you get them together?
Maybe you could get a picture of
them trying to--
hold it up so they can get a
picture there, just turn it
between you.
But work on it as you're doing
it.
Don't hold your hand in the way
the camera.
Yes?
Quiet a minute, yes?
STUDENT: Shouldn't the
structures of the models be
able to be bent a little?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's true.
It's true that the models have
fixed angles and don't distort
easily, these models.
If you made it with Fisher's
models, the ones that had
rubber tubing, you'd have no
problem making it, because
they're not space-filling
either.
And there's the question of how
big the atoms are, they're
a little bit crushable, right.
These models, obviously, are
more or less rigid.
And in fact, you can make
tetraphenylmethane, but as
we'll see shortly, once we get a
projector going for us, you
can't make hexaphenylethane.
Any luck?
I don't know why this is taking
so long.
I turned off the side one, and
somehow the center
one went off too.
I going to turn on one of the
other projectors, just in case
this one doesn't come on.
In fact, I'll turn them all on.
We'll see where we get any luck.
Ah, there we go.
OK.
So here you see what we were
just saying.
Steric hindrance in
triphenylmethyl causes twists
that reduce overlap by 25% from
what they would be in
diphenylmethyl, and makes
tetraphenyl[correction: methane]
very difficult to
prepare, not to mention
hexaphenylethane.
So, but Gomberg was able to make
tetraphenylmethane using this
trick that he'd learned in
Munich of knocking nitrogen
out and having the two radicals
come together.
And he tried, as we mentioned
last time, to prove that
that's what he had.
The analysis was correct.
And he was good at analysis,
remember.
And he got the right molecular
weight, almost. So then he
went back. He spent just one
year in Germany.
Not like Friedel who spent four
years first, and then 17
years in Paris.
Then he went back to Ann Arbor
and got back to work, stayed
there the rest of his life.
And he confirmed the molecular
weight by doing an even better
measurement, he got 318 versus
320.
So he was really confident that
he had
tetraphenylmethane.
But there was one thing that was
funny.
He nitrated it, did
electrophilic aromatic
substitution on the four
phenyls,
got the tetranitro compound and
he got it at 99.5% yield.
But there was a problem. He
wrote.
"Unlike trinitro
triphenlmethane... it does not
dissolve in sodium ethylate,"
that's ethoxide anion strong
base,
"nor does it give any
coloration..."
So these nitro compounds with a
lot of phenyls seemed to
dissolve in strong base and to
give colors,
but his compound didn't.
Now why does this dissolve in
strong base?
Any ideas?
What does base do with it,
strong base?
Wojtek?
STUDENT: It takes off the H
plus.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it takes off H
This is a very good anion.
It's triply benzylic, plus it
has the electron-withdrawing
nitro group, so it's easy to
pull off the proton and get
the anion, which then dissolves
and is colored.
It has an unusually high HOMO
and a low LUMO nearby, so the
electrons can move, absorbing
light that's
in the colored region.
OK, so it's possible to get
that.
Of course, he didn't know this
theory that we know.
So for him, it's was just funny
that it didn't dissolve
in base the way other
nitrophenyl compounds did.
But he wondered, how about
hexaphenylethane?
If you nitrate it, will it be
colored?
Will it dissolve in base?
So he set about trying to make
hexaphenylethane.
Now how did he try?
He tried using the techniques
that failed to make
tetraphenylmethane.
It's very much like Wurtz
coupling, right?
You put a metal in, pull out two
chlorides, the things come
together is the idea.
Here, it's plausible because
it's easy to pull that
chloride off, as we'll see
later.
So in fact he did get-- he
thought-- hexaphenylethane.
So he did analyses.
So he got the total of carbon
plus hydrogen-- that is CO2
and water that he burned it and
got-- was
93.97 by one method.
This is a method, not a run.
He did many, many analyses using
the same method.
Their average was 93.97.
He tried another method: 94.20,
94.00,
94.57.
Four different methods, maybe 20
analyses he did.
But he could never get it near
100%.
And he was confident of his
ability as an analytical
chemist. Remember all that time
he spent in lab.
Ultimately he used more than 17
different methods to
analyze it, and none of them
would give 100%.
So he concluded that there's
something else there besides
carbon and hydrogen.
And that something else is
oxygen.
Because if you have two oxygens
between the
triphenylmethyl groups, then the
sum of C and H is
93.82%, which is what he got
within a few parts per thousand.
So there must be O2 in
between. So he
prepared the authentic peroxide.
You can easily do an
SN2[correction: SN1] reaction,
because the chloride
will come away to give the
triphenylmethyl cation,
and then O2 minus 2 will go
between. So you can get
the authentic peroxide,
And it was the same compound.
So then he knew how to prepare
the hydrocarbon. You do it by
preparing it without oxygen
present.
It reacts easily with oxygen.
So he used a special apparatus
he said,
"with ground glass joints."
Then they used corks and
sometimes rubber stoppers, but
never or rarely, ground
glass joint.
That was really high tech.
But he did it, and he got the
compound
that analyzed correctly.
But he found it was very funny
because this substance not
only reacted with O2, it reacted
easily with Cl2, with
Br2, and even with I2, which you
remember
doesn't add to alkenes.
So this is a weird, unsaturated
compound.
So unsaturated it reacts
spontaneously even with I2.
And certainly hexaphenylethane
shouldn't do that,
Tetraphenylmethane didn't do
anything like that.
So this is from his paper in
1900, just at
the turn of the century.
He said, "Triphenylmethyl... The
experimental evidence
presented above forces me to the
conclusion that we have to
deal, here, with a free
radical..."
Remember where radicals came
from?
Remember, it was the
nomenclature in the 1830s, the
organic radical?
At first they thought they were
real things, Kolbe
thought he had made methyl, but
in fact he had made the
dimer ethane.
And then from then on, radical
was just a name.
It wasn't something that was
real, it
wasn't the organic element.
Here, he tried to make the dimer
hexaphenylethane but
concluded that he had the
monomer,
triphenylmethyl free radicals.
Not just names.
"On this assumption alone do the
results described above
become intelligible and receive
an adequate
explanation.
The action of zinc results, as
it seems to me, in the mere
abstraction of the halogen
leaving the free radical.
The radical so formed is
apparently stable, for it can
be kept both in solution and in
the dry crystalline state
for weeks."
So he had prepared a free
radical.
Now of course, when you do a
reaction, you either have to
go association/dissociation or
dissociation and then
association.
And when you dissociate from
carbon, you get something
that's trivalent.
And this was the first example
of an authentic trivalent
carbon compound.
So this is the watershed between
the 19th century, when
it was just making compounds and
things being mysterious,
and the 20th century when you
could begin to understand
mechanisms in terms of actually
knowing something
about these trivalent carbon
compounds.
And this was the first.
So this launched the American
century of chemistry, because
this experiment was done in
America, in Ann Arbor.
And here in October 1900, he
wrote a paper,
published it in America,
received October 4th.
"An Instance of Trivalent
Carbon: Triphenylmethyl." But
at the same time, he published
it in Germany.
A preliminary paper,
"Triphenylmethyl: a Case of
Trivalent Carbon," received the
1st of October, 1900.
So he published it both places
to cover his bases.
Now you remember, we talked
about American organic
chemistry and about James Mason
Crafts and that
essentially everything he did,
he did in Paris.
And many people thought he was
French He did essentially
nothing in the U.S. There were
people doing more than that,
but not a lot more than that.
All the center of gravity was in
Europe, especially in
Germany, at the end of the 19th
century.
But Gomberg comes along, born 25
years later.
Oh, I should have said that
there's an
exception, which is Yale.
Because Gibbs really made at
complete international splash
with his "Equilibrium of
Heterogeneous Substances,"
which was published the same
period as the
Friedel Crafts reaction.
But that was in France and this
was in America.
So in physical chemistry,
America had done something,
and it was Gibbs.
But in organic chemistry,
Gomberg was the first one to
really do something.
And these are Gomberg's
publications.
And contrast that with the
previous one.
So here, he went for just one
year to Munich and Heidelberg,
where he did this work and
prepared this compound, the
tetraphenylmethane, which was
itself notable.
But much more drastic was the
preparation of the radical
triphenylmethyl, which he did,
obviously, after he got back
to America.
So he published these things in
German, because that's where
the big readership was.
But within 10 years or so, he
was doing all his publishing
in the United States, and a lot
of publishing.
So in that 25 year period
between Friedel and Gomberg,
things started really happening
in this country.
And then after the Second World
War, of course, Europe
had such difficulty that things
really took off here,
and it was a long time for them
to catch up again.
So this launched the American
chemical century.
And incidentally, one other
thing about it, is the big
German journal for organic
chemistry was Berichte der
Deutschen Chemischen
Gesellschaft.
"The Reports of the German
Chemical Society." And in 1900
there were 4,290 pages, and I
leafed through them to see how
many graphs there were, how many
quantitative things were
being discussed.
This was mainly a journal of
organic chemistry and there
were very, very few graphs.
In fact, in two of the papers
from this period here,
Gomberg's papers had more graphs
than all those things
in all of 1900 in the German
main literature.
So it showed not only were
things coming to America, but
physical-organic chemistry, the
quantitative approach to
organic chemistry was rising as
well.
Now I said I had second thoughts
on the Friedel-Crafts
reaction, of what I told you
last time.
So I'm going to take just a
minute to
tell you about those.
So we talked about rearrangement
happening in
Friedel-Crafts alkylation and
the idea that you can get
a chloride being complexed with
triphenylmethyl chloride,
which makes it a good leaving
group.
Which means that the phenyl can
come in and displace that,
it's essentially an
SN1[correction: SN2] reaction.
Here's the substrate with its
good leaving group, and the
high HOMO here comes in
displaces, and then you lose a
hydrogen from the same place and
get the product.
You get the normal propyl
product, the first one there.
But if it dissociates a little
bit and rearranges with a
hydride shift, then you get the
other product.
This is what we talked about.
So we said that this is what
gives the primary product,
it's essentially an
SN1[correction: SN2] reaction.
But this SN2[correction: SN1]
reaction after rearrangment,
when you get the
more stable secondary cation,
then it can dissociate and
then you get the so-called
cumene, isopropylbenzene.
Now that may be true, but it may
be wrong, too.
I got thinking about this.
OK, so suppose it rotated so
that
methyl was on the backside.
Then what might you expect to
happen?
What happened over here to get
the secondary cation?
STUDENT: Hydride shift.
PROFESSOR: It was a hydride
shift, right?
What might you get now?
STUDENT: Methide shift.
PROFESSOR: A methide shift.
And methides and hydrides
rearrange at
about the same rate.
So why not do this, why not do
methide shifts?
So what do you get if you do a
methide shift?
You get that.
But it's the same thing you had
before, it's a degenerate
rearrangment.
It's still the primary compound
and then you could do
the SN1 and get the product, so
it doesn't make any
difference that you do a methide
shift.
But suppose the methide shift
gets stuck halfway across.
Suppose it stops there.
Because another way to draw that
is as protonated
cyclopropane.
It's cyclopropane that's taken
on an extra proton.
And that substance has been
studied.
And it's known that its
stability is between the
primary cation and the secondary
cation.
So suppose you got that, what
would that do?
Well, you could have the
nucleophile attack that, I
mean the methyl plus is a great
leaving group.
So you could do that and again,
it would still give
that same product if you had the
protonated cyclopropane
instead of this thing doing the
alkylation.
Now in fact, Norman Deno at Penn
State University in 1968,
unbeknownst to me, had actually
done that reaction.
He took benzene and cyclopropane
and reacted it
with acid, and got these
products.
And he used deuterium here.
So there's deuterium in this
normal
propylbenzene, just one
deuterium.
Now what I want you to tell me
is where you expect it to be.
On which carbon should that
deuterium be? which of the
three carbons?
Let's suppose that it happens by
making protonated
cyclopropane.
Chris, what do you think?
STUDENT: The terminal one?
PROFESSOR: It should be the
terminal one, because if you
put it on here then you
displace--
that'll be the methyl group and
the deuterium should be
there, one deuterium.
Here's what he found.
Where is it?
3/7 of it is where Chris said,
2/7 here and 2/7 here.
It's completely scrambled,
right?
There are three hydrogens here,
two here, and two here.
And that one deuterium is
completely scrambled among
those positions.
How did it get scrambled?
Well, this corner protonated
cyclopropane very easily
rearranges to edge protonated
cyclopropane.
And then that can become
protonated at this corner, and
then this edge, and then this
corner, and then this edge,
and then back to where you
started.
And when it's that CH3 it
doesn't have to be the
deuterium you added that moves,
it could
have been the hydrogen.
So everything gets scrambled
very quickly
going around there.
And in fact, this was shown in a
key experiment by a man
named Richard Baird, who was an
assistant professor here in
this department in 1964.
And it was on the basis of that
that Deno tried this
experiment.
So protonated cyclopropane does
give this compound.
So now we have a question, which
of these is the thing
that gives the Friedel Crafts
product?
Is it an SN2 reaction with this,
or an SN1 reaction that
involves the protonated
cyclopropane?
And it could be either.
And no one knows, as far as I am
aware.
I've just been going through the
literature in the last two
days on this.
I don't think anybody knows
this.
I tried to call Professor Olah,
and wasn't able to get him,
at University of Southern
California, who got the Nobel
Prize for Friedel Crafts
things, and I haven't been able
to get him yet.
But Professor Saunders, who
knows a lot about this,
doesn't think he knows.
We'll see.
But anyhow, I think it's not
known.
So what I want you guys to do is
to try to think up an
experiment that can tell you
whether it's the SN2 or the
SN1 mechanism.
And I'll give you a hint, I
think the good experiments
involve isotopes.
So here's a problem for you.
So maybe you can become famous
and determine the mechanism of
the Friedel Crafts reaction
after 143 years.
OK, now onto the next subject,
which is carbonyl compounds.
I didn't bring the Jones
textbook along, but carbonyl
compounds are discussed in
Chapter 16 to 19,
which is 268 pages.
It's about a quarter of the text
book, I think, and that's
not atypical.
You have many other texts and
you can check, but there's a
lot of stuff in there about
carbonyl compounds.
The good news is that almost all
of it is review, because
we've talked a lot about the
reactivity of carbonyl
compounds.
So Chapter 16, for example, is
aldehydes and ketones.
So for the rest of this lecture,
I'm just going to go
over the big view of this, and
then in the next lectures
we'll take a more detailed view
of some of the lore.
So we talked about before that
the carbonyl compound is
stable, but it's reactive.
Those things we've said before
seem contradictory.
You have the average bond
energies we've looked at
before for the single and double
bond, and for the
single and double bonds to
oxygen.
And we've seen that the second
bond in carbon is very much
weaker than the first bond.
But the second bond for oxygen
is stronger
than the first bond.
And it's not all due to the pi
bond, because it has also to
do with a change and
hybridization of the carbon,
the sigma bond changes when you
form a double bond.
So it's very stable compared to
carbon-carbon double bonds.
But it's also reactive because
it has a very
low LUMO the pi*.
Now just to give you something
to practice with about NMR, to
see how people figured out
chemical shifts in NMR. They
did it by taking a compound, a
known compound like acetaldehyde
where n is 3 here, you'll see
why I used n.
And they found it had two peaks,
199.6 and 31.2 in the
CMR spectrum, carbon magnetic
resonance.
And then they put another carbon
on and found peaks at
those positions, and then
another one on and found peaks
at those positions.
And then they did a ketone,
acetone, and found peaks at
those positions.
And with one more carbon,
2-butanone, they found that.
And with 2-pentanone they found
that, and with
3-pentanone they found that.
Now with that empirical evidence
behind you, I want
you to figure out what this CMR
spectrum is of and which
peaks are which.
And that's taken from that Chem
220 problem site that
we've mentioned before.
So there are the values of the
chemical shifts in this proton
decoupled CMR spectrum, and use
the table to identify what
each of those carbons is.
And in the process, you'll
figure out what regularities
there are within this table, and
how you go about figuring
out new things.
And just to give you an extra
hint, here's the proton
magnetic resonance spectrum of
the same compound.
Notice this is 400 MHz for
protons.
It was a 100 MHz for carbon.
That's the same magnet, because
the proton is four
times as strong as carbon.
And just to help you out with
this, we can blow up each of
those peaks and see what the
spin-spin splitting is.
And there they are with the
values of their chemical
shifts and here's the scale for
the detail, that's 20 Hz.
So this splitting here is 1.8 Hz
and the one over here is
6.8 Hz, just for reference.
So there are two problems for
you.
Make your name by devising an
experiment to prove the
mechanism of the Friedel Crafts
reaction, and figure
out what this compound is.
Ok now, So carbonyl is very
stable, but it's also,
paradoxically, reactive.
And we know that's because of
pi*.
We'll see other ways as well.
So the nucleophile comes in,
we've done this is a zillion
times, and we have nucleophilic
addition.
And last semester, we talked
about the Buergi-Dunitz angle,
and all this is discussed in
Chapter 16.
And you remember, this contrasts
with C=C, where the addition
reactions are electrophilic, not
nucleophilic.
So then you bring a proton on
and you get an alcohol.
And especially interesting
alcohols, that will be
discussed in Chapter 16, are
ones where you form a new bond
to R, where the nucleophile is
an alkyl group.
For example, methyllithium has
that property, and we talked
about that some last semester.
Or where the nucleophile is H
minus, as in
lithium aluminum hydride.
So here are some sections that
talk about that.
And again, we'll talk more about
this.
Now, a different kind of
reactivity is when one of the
substituents on the carbonyl can
be a leaving group in an
SN2 reaction, so it's an OK
anion.
Because when you do that,
there's something else you can
do at this stage.
Of course, you can reverse it,
you can bring these electrons
in to reform the double bond and
lose the
nucleophile and go back.
But as in SN2 reactions, you can
also lose the leaving
group if it's a reasonable
anion.
So you can go like this, and now
what you've
done is not an addition.
What kind of reaction is this,
instead of an addition?
What's overall?
Linda?
STUDENT: Substitution.
PROFESSOR: It's a substitution
instead of an addition.
So nucleophilic substitution of
things that are called acid
derivatives--
these things when L is a leaving
group, when that thing
is a leaving group are called
acid derivatives.
So it's
association/dissociation.
It's not like SN2 where you go
through a pentavalent
transition state.
This has an actual intermediate,
this has a
finite lifetime.
So it's association and then
dissocation, as in aromatic
substitution.
Remember, electrophilic aromatic
substitution goes
through a tetravalent carbon,
then the proton gets lost and
you have the electrophile left
on there.
And that's what's discussed in
Chapter 18.
But there are other ways to go
at it too, because the oxygen
has unshared pairs, so acids can
attack it.
So you have an acid come in, for
example a proton to
protonate it and get that
cation, and then you can have
electrophilic addition.
So a nucleophile then can come
in on a second step.
In the previous slide, we had
the nucleophile come in first
and then brought a proton in
later.
Now we're bringing the proton in
first on the oxygen and
bringing a nucleophile in later.
So we get compounds that have OH
and a nucleophile on there.
Now what nucleophiles can you
use?
Notice that this is much easier
than for C=C. So the
nucleophile can be OH, in which
case this thing over
here is called a hydrate.
It's H20 added to the carbonyl.
Or it's sometimes called a gem
diol--
gem for geminal.
Gemini is twins, right, so it's
twin OHs on there.
Or it can be OR, and we've
already talked about that,
hemiacetal, or on the way to an
acetal.
Or it could be a nitrogen, and
then the equivalent of a
hemiacetal for nitrogen is
called a carbinolamine.
And you can unzip this, of
course, and
go back to the carbonyl.
But if you have two groups on
there, you could unzip, losing
the other group and keeping the
nucleophile.
And then you have a nucleophile
double bond.
That's what the imine is, a
carbon-nitrogen double bond.
Or you can have a bisulfite
addition product, or CN.
That one's special, because you
form a new
carbon-carbon bond.
You're always on the lookout for
things that will form new
carbon-carbon bonds, not just
change the functional group.
So that's called a cyanohydrin.
So there are sections 16.6 to
16.11 about that in the
Jones book, but all these things
will be covered in all
these textbooks.
ow the reason this was stable,
one reason it was easy to
protonate that was you have this
resonance structure.
But notice that if you have a
proton here, on the carbon
adjacent to the carbonyl--
that's the alpha position.
So if you have an alpha proton,
then a nucleophile can
act as a base.
So a base can come in and take
the proton.
So instead of attacking here, it
can attack here and
generate this double bond.
And you remember what those
things are called?
Enols.
So that this is an allylic
rearrangement, the fourth
pattern of reactivity is allylic
rearrangement, ketone to enol.
As I've been going along, I've
been numbering all the
different ways carbonyls react.
So now you could a bring a low
LUMO in here and have the
electrons of the double bond
attack it.
So this is a double bond.
So this is like electrophilic
addition to a double bond,
except especially good because
you have the unshared pair on
the oxygen that can help out and
make this easy to do that.
So it's better than other
carbon-carbon double bonds.
So the enol is essentially a
carbon nucleophile.
It can attack low LUMOs
especially easy.
So you get something like this.
And notice that after you lost
the proton then, what you have--
what you've done is to do a
substitution at the alpha
position, an
electrophilic substitution at
the alpha position of a ketone
or an aldehyde.
So that's another pattern of
reactivity, and that's Chapter
19, these reactions of enols.
So enols, enolates, and
enolization.
A little bit from Chapter 19,
here.
So here we have this alpha
hydrogen, we bring the base
in, as we said last time.
This time, we're doing it
without having first put
something on the O and having a
double--
so what we've made now is and
anion.
Its pKa is 19.
Pretty acidic.
But what's it normally for
alkanes, if you didn't have
the carbonyl there? You told me
last time, Chris.
STUDENT: A little over 50.
PROFESSOR: A little over 50,
right.
So here we've got 31 powers of
10 advantage.
That's how easy it is to make
the enolate, the anion.
Once you have the enolate with a
double bond here and a
charge on the oxygen, then you
can put the proton on the
oxygen and you have an enol.
So another number that's
interesting is the equilibrium
constant between here and here.
So this is for forming the
anion, this is for the allylic
rearrangement of the proton.
So it's 5 times 10 to the minus
9th.
So you're going to have very
little enol
compared to the ketone.
But notice at equilibrium,
they'll be in equilibrium with
the same anion.
Because if you lose the proton
from here, you get the same
enolate anion that you get from
losing the proton here.
So if this is ever so much more
energetic, higher in
energy than this, then this one
is going to
be unusually acidic.
It's going to be easy for it to
lose that proton.
Since the ketone is about 11
kilocalories below the enol,
the pKa of this is about 11.
Very acidic.
Remember, normal alcohols are
like 16 and 17 pKa.
So this is very acidic. Now
let's go to--
if one's good, more is better.
Put two carbonyls adjacent to
this alpha thing, so now both
of them can stabilize it.
And now the pKa nine, and the
equilibrium
constant is now 3.
It's better to have this than to
have this.
Whereas here, it was 10 to the
minus eight of
this compared to this.
Now it's three times as much
this as this at equilibrium.
Notice, incidentally, this would
be hydrogen bonded.
And you could imagine that the
hydrogen could shift
from here to here--
this double bond to here, this
double bond to here--
the hydrogen could bounce back
between those two things.
In fact, it's even conceivable
it would
be halfway in between.
And Professor Vaccaro in this
lab is doing a lot of work on
that kind of thing, compounds of
that sort.
So here, the ketone is
approximately equal to the
enol, because of the help from
conjugation and
from hydrogen bonding.
Now if you have these double
bonds in there, now this
compound is favored by a factor
of 10 to the 13th.
This enol is 10 to the 13th
favored at equilibrium over
this. so you got none of this,
it's all here.
Why?
Because this one is--
you've gained the aromaticity,
that 30 kcal/mole
that you didn't have over here.
So the ketone is now 17
kilocalories above the enol.
Here, the enol was 11
kilocalories above the ketone.
It's a complete range of ketone
to enol.
The pKa of this thing here is
10.
It's the same as this.
The anion is only about 13
kcal/mole
above phenol.
So it's very easy to lose that.
And phenol, if you ever get it
on your skin, burns like fire.
It's just terrible because as an
organic compound, it
dissolves in your lipids and
then it's a strong acid.
So if you ever get it, you'll
know.
Did you ever get into nettles?
Stinging nettles?
That's phenols for you.
And the pKa in this case is -3.
So this really easily loses a
proton.
Now, how about reactions of
carboxylic acids?
We went through, I think it was
five patterns of
reactivity of carbonyl groups.
Now we're going to look at the
carboxylic acids, which are in
Chapter 17, and see what
patterns of reactivity we're
going to expect.
Well first, you can get
addition, just as if it were a
carbonyl group.
So you can imagine doing that
kind of thing and
there, we'll see examples.
Another possibility is to do
substitution at carbon.
So this is like the OH became a
leaving group somehow.
And then OR came in.
So it's just like the ketones.
We said if there was a leaving
group here, here the leaving
group is OH.
Or we make it into a better
leaving group somehow, maybe
by protonating it, something
like that.
So we can get substitution at
carbon. But there's another
possibility in the acid.
You could start here, and you
could do the
substitution at oxygen.
Get the same product, R on R,O,
C=O,
get the same thing, but make
this bond, rather
than making that bond.
So you can have substitution at
carbon, you can have
substitution at oxygen.
And there's another possibility,
of course,
substitution at the alpha
carbon.
So if you have an RH here, an
alpha hydrogen, then,
as we saw with aldehydes and
ketones--
you can do a substitution there.
And the good news in all this,
is almost
all of this is review.
In fact, I should have said one
thing on
the previous slide.
That when you have the OH and
put the R on, making the R-O
bond, that's an alpha
substitution also.
It's just that it's an oxygen
rather than a carbon that has
the alpha hydrogen.
So you can have that, or on the
carbon side.
And the good news is, very much
of this is review.
For example, if you look at
pages 785 to 787, sections
16.9 to 16.10 in the Jones book,
you'll find that it's an
old favorite of ours.
So let's just conclude the hour,
here, by going through
that again.
It's the mechanism for acid
catalyzed
hydrolysis of acetal.
We've already done this, but it
doesn't
hurt to do it again.
And it's this part of the text.
So we have this acetal, and the
idea is to hydrolyze
it, to go back to an aldehyde.
And how do we do it, do you
remember acid catalysis?
Where do we start in?
Kate, are you going to help us
out, here?
Where does an acid attack this
compound, H plus?
STUDENT: Something to do with
one of the oxygens?
PROFESSOR: What is it about an
oxygen that makes the H plus
want to go there?
STUDENT: The lone pair.
PROFESSOR: The lone pair.
So the goal is going to be--
it's two steps.
First we're going to remove OR
and replace it by OH, then
we're going to remove the other
OR and replace it by OH.
So the way we do it is with H
plus, as Kate tells us, and we
have the unshared pair, and we
do that and we get here.
This is exactly one we went over
before, but the old ones
are the best ones, right?
OK, what's going to happen next?
John, what do you say?
Remember what the goal is?
What are we trying to do in the
first stage?
STUDENT: Remove RO?
PROFESSOR: We want to remove RO,
how are we going to do it?
STUDENT: I'm not sure.
PROFESSOR: Well, we could just
have it leave now, right?
Remove ROH.
What do we leave behind when we
pull off
ROH from this thing?
Where do the electrons go--
it's this bond we're going to
break--
where are the electrons going
go, are they going to go on
the O, or are they going to go
on the C?
STUDENT: On the O.
PROFESSOR: On the O, right?
Because it's O plus, so it's
going to gain full ownership
of that pair of electrons, so it
becomes ROH neutral.
So what's left behind on the
carbon?
Nothing, right?
The electrons went away.
So what do we draw, then?
How do we draw that?
We have ROCH2 left, what do we
draw on the CH2?
STUDENT: A plus charge
PROFESSOR: Right, OK.
So it's going to do that, and
we'll get that.
If this weren't RO,
if it were just H, say,
that would be a crummy reaction.
Why does it work here?
What's good about that cation?
STUDENT: The lone pairs on the
oxygen get stable.
PROFESSOR: The vacant orbital is
able to stabilize those
electrons, so the thing gets
unusually stable.
So you have that, and bingo.
So we've got the first RO off.
Now we have to
replace it by OH.
Cassie, how are we going to do
that?
How are we going to put OH on
here after we took RO off?
STUDENT: It can attack the O on
the pi*.
PROFESSOR: Speak up, please?
STUDENT: The O on the pi*?
PROFESSOR: The O of the what?
STUDENT: pi*.
PROFESSOR: OK, so we want to put
OH on that cabon.
How do we do it?
Say it again, please?
STUDENT: Can you attack the pi*?
[correction: Cassie is at least
partly right. The instructor is
thinking of the resonance
structure on the left].
PROFESSOR: I'm not sure what pi*
you're talking about.
There's a pi here, in this
resonance structure, but the
important thing that we have is
a vacant orbital on carbon.
STUDENT: There are lone pairs on
oxygen.
PROFESSOR: What oxygen?
O2?
STUDENT: Of the alcohol.
PROFESSOR: So suppose it attacks
the unshared pair on
the alcohol, you form a bond
here.
Now you're here.
That's going backwards.
So we're going to need something
else.
STUDENT: You have a water group.
PROFESSOR: Yigit, what would you
use?
STUDENT: Water?
PROFESSOR: Water.
So if you put water in, that
cation is usually stable, as
John told us.
So we bring water in, now we
make that bond and now we have
OH there, but we also have H. Is
that a problem?
Yigit?
We want OH here, not H2O.
No, we just lost the proton.
So we've accomplished our first
step up here, right?
We have a hemiacetal and we can
check that one off.
Now we have to take the second
RO off and replace it with OH.
How are we going to do that?
Nathan?
STUDENT: Same way.
PROFESSOR: Tell me what we're
going to do.
What's the first step?
STUDENT: An H plus--
PROFESSOR: And where do we want
to put the H plus?
Here or here?
STUDENT: On the top one.
PROFESSOR: On the top one, OK.
So we remove the second one by
bringing H plus in and put it
on the top.
Next?
STUDENT: Lose the water.
PROFESSOR: Lose water.
Pardon me, lose alcohol
to get this, and now?
STUDENT: Add water.
PROFESSOR: Add water.
No, we don't need to add water.
If we wanted to put the second
one in, true.
I misled you.
But really where you go is here.
So you just lose a proton.
So you've taken the ketal to a
carbonyl by way of a
hemiacetal or a hemiketal.
So the overall transformation,
then, is water plus acetal,
acid catalyzed to give carbonyl
plus two ROHs.
And we wrote it this way before.
They come together and pull it
apart, and so the H2O enters
all three molecules.
OK, that's how much we wanted to
do today.
We've made it.
We made it to the end, we're
caught up, actually, with
where we were last year.